there are so many video games at this
week talking about a bunch of today but
at one game that people aren't really
talking about though that too much but
is that worth having a chat about is
vermintide and Scott Butterworth you
reviewed the game arey you've played a
bunch of it and Scott first of all what
is vermin size and why should I play
yeah it's it really slipped it under the
writer actually came out a couple weeks
ago during like you know Call of Duty
just came out and halo just came out and
SAS agreed was earlier in October and
now we have fallout today Tomb Raider
it's just it was such a a packed few
weeks of game releases that I'm not sure
anyone really noticed that this little
game came out but it's it's a game
called Warhammer the end times of
vermintide it's a very long title but it
is a Warhammer property said in the end
times lore which is a specific part of
the Warhammer lorg there's a lot of like
there's a lot of stuff in the universe
so is this like high fantasy yeah it's
like a very grim dark high fantasy it's
very like everything's just dark and
gritty and angry in that I mean just
look at the trailer right that's yeah
the tone so yeah so basically what this
game is it's it's Leopard edge straight
up it's its valves left for dead but
with rats instead of zombies the Skaven
is they're known in the universe but
they're basically as you saw like
humanoid rats with like you know crude
weaponry like the it works in Lord of
the Rings yeah basically yeah and
actually I mean it's it's down to left
for dead it's all Eve all the details
are straight huttle left for dead
including like the special enemy types
and special infected so you have like a
smoker equivalent like a collector
equivalent like they're a Boomer in
there somewhere there is yeah yeah
there's that the gas rats they call them
they like basically fire gas grenades
that you and this huge cloud of green
smoke appears and yeah I mean so it's
it's a pretty shameless invitation but
honestly it's not a bad thing I mean it
actually really works and in a way it's
almost impressive that they have made a
game that is as fun and plays arguably
as well as left 4 dead and with you know
I would imagine a smaller team I mean
they don't get a ton of points for
originality because yep taking about
seven years ago but yeah you can even
saw in the last clip like your allies
they use either glowing silhouette just
it's like yeah it's straight up left for
dead
Mary you played a bunch of left 4 dead 1
on 2 and it has been a while since I
left that game came out so like what I'm
trying to mention that's fine like what
what's your impression of it did you
enjoy playing it yeah you know you
really sum it up well it's absolutely
there's the hunter which is it's fine
like it's okay I wanted to play worse
part about left 4 dead is that I've
played those levels so many times yeah I
can't play them anymore I can't play
them anymore
you even did the gnome run yeah you do
all the way you go all the way and you
play in as many different ways as you
can and you play the versus modes and
everything and you eventually you're
like burnout on it just sucked it dry
it's like it's there's nothing left to
kind of yeah it's so much melee combat
is a huge focus it's not just you know
it obviously left for dead was guns guns
guns guns this you actually have both
ranged and melee options the melee is
somewhat simplistic I mean there's just
it's the trigger buttons just one button
two attacks and you just aim point your
camera that enemy and pull the trigger
till the thing dies but it's still very
satisfying like it's really gruesome and
the cooperative gameplay you know it's
very fast and frantic in the same way
that left for dead was like really hard
focusing on on co-op see like you really
really need to work you're out there
just like in left 4 dead which I loved
about that game right you could not play
it and be a hero you need to work
together yeah you will straight-up die
you can get your whole team absolutely
and this incentivizes you to play
together because there's Secrets
throughout the world and they kinda yeah
you in certain way and there's a loot
system and actually one of the ways to
the loot system works is you can find
objects in the environment that take up
an inventory slots so like you can find
a tome that takes up your medical slot
so you can no longer heal yourself but
if you finish the level while still
carrying that you potentially unlock
better loot and if any any single team
member is carrying a tome everybody
benefits from everybody potentially gets
better loot so that further incentivizes
teamwork it's really actually very
clever the only problem is that the
loose systems like pretty superficial
you kind of run out of new stuff pretty
quickly ok so it's a great idea that I
think could have been executed a little
bit better but still like it's it's very
cool that they even thought to include
ways to force people to work together
and the characters in Leopard I wanted
to obviously like very we remember those
characters but they were kind
to standard the generic like there
wasn't much benefit to being one or the
other
yeah and this are the classes do some
people do magic like how does that's a
breaker they're all different that's
really wonderful too because you can
play it the same level as a different
character and have a completely
different experience of course you're
seeing the bright wizard wizard which is
up like basically a pyro Mancera like
they're they have this
oh yeah it's a more distance more range
there's like a bow and arrow person
there's a dwarf that kind of has like
big battle axe yeah we sort of thing
happen there as well imperial soldier
with a blunderbuss like a basically a
medieval shotgun so when you stuck with
the with the weapons you have at the
start down or you know a lot more that's
sort of what the whole loot system is
built around you unlock both new ranged
and melee weapons and actually generally
they're not you know clearly better than
the previous weapon but they might open
up a new play style like to the right
wizard moved is looking at the standard
weapon that you start with just kind of
shoots generic fireballs yeah but a
later weapon that you unlock which isn't
necessary powerful but kind of works
differently allows you to sort of summon
fire from across the map so it's more of
an area of effective okay as opposed to
like launching projectiles you can burn
a whole bunch or a whole group a pack
that's closely packed together get them
all in like one shot so it just opens up
new options as you unlocked you for
rewarding this is the suite level
basically like it's actually what I
think the first it's one of the very
early one of the early levels and you
blow this horn which is literally a
whole horde of these rats towards you
and then as that happens eventually a
hole in the floor will open up it's this
extra level but it's like that great end
part of any level where you just know
yeah just Rams are coming and you got to
defend for at least like a couple
minutes it's it's just like there's a
smoker oh yeah you're right there there
are pack masters in this which is
actually based on something in more
hemorrhoid it's it is really rewarding
to like get these final moments you're
you're kind of like bashing into all
these dudes at the very end and trying
to survive so if this is the ending of
one level what are we talking about in
terms of like level design or not not
design but like how many levels are
there headed a connect together is there
a now
that's tying it together there are 13
levels total they all sort of stand
alone there they're totally discrete so
you can play you can play them in any
order you have to unlock them to begin
with so guys there's this kind of an
order but in terms of story there's no
you know clear progression between them
they're sort of given justification for
why you're doing this particular mission
as you start out but they're not
necessarily interconnected it's all just
like oh man the rats are coming we're
boned
let's let's like stop this however we
can so one machine you're like trying to
recover ammunition another one you're
trying to you know stymie there you
basically infiltrate escape and base and
like destroy their their home base did
you feel compelled to do the next level
or is it kind of like dropping back to
matchmaking and just doing another
random level umm it's the motivation
there's certainly no like narrative
motivation to continue but just the
gameplay and the momentum of that
feeling of you know you get to the end
of a level and it really amped up
because you just you know went through
this whole crescendo at the end of a
level it definitely makes you want to
continue playing and you can vote as a
team on whether you want to return to
sort of the home base and you check on
your loot or upgrade your systems or
anything or if you just want to jump
directly into the next map like I said
there they're sort of designed to be
discrete standalone and and replayable
so you can kind of approach the game
everyone you can just play a ton of
missions all in a row you can do them
one at a time and go back and upgrade
your stuff every time you know it kind
of depends on how you want to approach
again Warhammer end-times vermintide 7
in a 10 on gamespot.com look again
before we leave yeah what are the
aspects where does it kind of fall short
I know it's a multiplayer only kind of
focus game it's 30 bucks yeah very
certain would have been nice if there
had been a versus mode like in in
left4dead which was sort of 8
symmetrical that she plays the zombies
mom I didn't punish the game too much
for that because it is a lower price
point and I mean that's kind of imaging
debate I mean I don't think that it's a
reviewers job to determine the value of
a dollar so I generally don't really
consider price when I'm scoring a game
or you know but I do think there are
certain expectations that come with
price points so I didn't you know you
know like oh this game doesn't have vs.
it's a 7 out of 10 but something to be
mindful of I think a bigger problem is
that the ally AI is pretty awful Oh see
there is an AI yes can't play
there are four characters at all times
and it's under you and humans or you and
the computer and they're not wrong is
dumb it's garbage and it's feed on
garbage like it's not like in left for
dead you could play with AI yeah they
were fine they were fine they were it
was hard this is like a goodbye it's you
can't get by no one
she does just they'll just like run up
and do stuff while you're dying and it's
like no why come back you know I've
heard it's gotten better since launch
but I was just playing the game last
week and it was still clearly a problem
I mean that and like the loot system not
being as fully realized as it probably
should have been was also like not great
I think those those are the big ones
those are the big issues also that it
was nice of the characters were
individuals and and and we're a little
more unique but none of them really do
anything that's all that mechanically
exciting like yeah you can aim down
sight but it's like okay that's the
thing we can do in a lot of games yeah
so it would have been nice to see a
little more originality rather than just
you know sort of uninventive new ideas
for semi characters cool interesting
game though Warhammer end-times
vermintide if you can get all of those
words editing method was a lot of words
a lot of words seven out of ten on
gangster comm available now on Steam for
30 bones and let us know what you think
of verbal time now review and the
comment box